Michelle you were here last year with
this I'm going to watch a war you're
here this year for the café de Flore or
even 12 Cassavetes awards has not come
with cash unlike last year oh yeah oh no
it was great the casual I got last year
really helped make helps make up tips I
mean healthy prompt day helped me live
while I was trying to rank all of all
the production perfect and you know help
me go on press toward stuff so it was
series going to help both and it's
always nice get money but I'm perfectly
have to do just the honor this thing's
heaven I'd normally so I can melt down
all
I say absolutely yeah I mean we're not
ready at the Oscars so having a forum
you know this event that is specifically
just to celebrate this particular can at
this kind of work which is always
dependently encourages you to pick up a
camera and go out and support without
having to wait for you know I'm scholars
in studio backing it is really really
awesome thank you yes what has been the
most challenging thing had to overcome
in your career what's in the most
challenging thing to overcome in my
career what answer I mean the thing is
so awesome about this time of filmmaking
is it's pumping the self-produced and
seven people is also selfish than I
really have looked at the resources i
had a so Tolan I you know ask
friends / of health ins I barber the
bacon we didn't and I threw together a
movie and now if you can do that and you
can actually shoot digitally and you can
you know if you write specifically to
make the movie that's affordable you can
even actually no I can't I cut out old
gum balances card services outside of
the drag but you know certain kind of
movies on character base cards you can
really do it on the cheap you know and
you don't have to wait for a fitting to
get me permission to make your work so i
can't really complain about any pasta
let's go early hominid yep
do you think that Catherine's nomination
makes a big difference for women in
Hollywood especially I she went who I
think have insomnia makes me different
strong in Hollywood um I know I knew we
knew you really really want to win but
that's mostly because I think they're
loveless about song to download so yeah
I mean I I think it's to be nice for
going to get your for change with Jeter
must be nice anything else what
congratulations what do you know now
that you wish you knew at the beginning
of your career I no no I wish I so much
money now so I don't have a thousand I
never well thank you go
you